Hi, Mystery Recapped here. Today I am going to
explain a Sci-Fi Drama film called “The Day Of
The Triffids”. Watch out and take care!
Dr. Bill Masen is a biotech engineer at a
research company called Triffoil. He specializes
in a tall, carnivorous plant called the Triffids.
The plant contains an oil that is an alternative
to fossil fuel. Over the past thirty years,
Triffids have become man’s best friend and have
helped eradicate global warming. But, many do not
know that the carnivorous plant is a real danger
to humans if left unattended. Thirty years ago,
Masen’s mother, who was also a researcher,
was killed by a Triffid. Masen knows that
if necessary, Triffids will feed on humans. Its
branches are extremely venomous that can blind
a person in only seconds. The breeding of the
plant is licensed and done away from cities.
When a plant shows an abnormality, Masen is
called to check on it. While he is at it,
the branches grip his arm and his associate has
to tase them away. Meanwhile, an anti Triffoil
activist breaches the premises and enters the
Orchard where all the male Triffids are kept.
The security cameras alert the officials
who send backup to get the man out safely.
Masen and his colleague Lucy run to the
Orchard and try to calm the man. Suddenly,
a Triffid branch attacks Masen’s eyes but misses
it. The backup arrives and gets everyone out
safely whereas Masen is poisoned by the minor
cut. Lucy rushes him to the hospital in London.
After giving Masen an antivenom, the doctor
bandages his eyes and asks him to rest for
twenty-four hours. In the meantime, the entire
world is waiting for a meteor shower that is
about to take place at night. A reporter named Joe
Clayton interviews an astrophysicist. According
to him, the sun will release an unbelievably vast
explosion of gas and nuclear fire, making it seem
like fireworks in the sky. Yet, it is proven
that the fireworks won’t do any harm to humans
or the earth. He asks the public to enjoy the
once in the lifetime experience to their best.
A few hours later, when it gets dark in London,
the fireworks start. Joe broadcasts it live from
the heart of London. Everyone in the world
watches the burning sky in awe. Lucy feels
bad for Masen that he couldn’t experience such
a unique phenomenon. Passengers of an airplane
flying above London also witness the fireworks
and are mesmerized by them. Among the passengers
is a man named Torrance who doesn’t appear to care
about the natural fireworks. He simply sleeps with
an eye mask while others get up from their seats
to look outside. A few minutes into the fireworks,
a blinding bright light flashes on the earth.
Because of it, all the TVs and radios lose signal.
The light is so bright that people can hardly keep
their eyes open. A while after everything ends,
Masen wakes up on the hospital bed, with his eyes
still bandaged. Outside, everyone is panicking
because the light has caused all of them to
lose their eyesight. A confused Masen opens the
bandages from his eyes and can see clearly. Back
in the airplane, Torrance wakes up and realizes
what is going on. The plan is about to crash
because even the pilots have also gone blind.
Amidst the chaos, he collects all the life
jackets, blows them up, and uses them to keep
himself safe in the bathroom. The plane crashes
near a hospital in London. All passengers die in
the crash but Torrance somehow survives with only
minor injuries. After coming out of the wreckage,
he smiles at the victory, not showing
any remorse at the death of the others.
Meanwhile, Masen tries to find the doctor in the
crowd but even the doctor is blind and has no idea
what is going on. When he registers that there
is going to be a power outage soon, he runs back
to the lab to keep the Triffids confined.
If the plants get out of the lab somehow,
they will breed at an exponential rate and kill
everyone on earth. Somewhere else, the reporter
Joe Clayton wakes up in the middle of the ruins
of a building. Unlike most, she still has her
eyesight. Joe makes it to the streets and realizes
what is going on. She tries asking for help but a
blind policeman holds her hostage, urging her
to take him home. Before he can do any harm,
Masen saves her. They plan to go to the Whitehall
together to find out what exactly is going on.
Somewhere else, Torrance takes full advantage of
the situation and steals everything he can from
the stores. He also takes a policeman’s gun
for protection and makes his way to a hotel.
Back on the Triffid farm, everyone,
including Lucy, has lost their eyesight.
The activist who was confined in a room, however,
can still see. Taking advantage of the situation,
he opens the doors to the orchard and
lets the Triffids free. The next morning,
Joe and Masen reach Whitehall but see that a
crowd of blind people has gathered in front of it.
They try communicating with the blind guards
who start to shoot each other. Following that,
the two drive to the Triffid farm. When they reach
there, the lab is in ruins with dead bodies of
the workers lying everywhere. Masen finally
registers the seriousness of the situation,
now that the Triffids have escaped. They go to
his lab and retrieve a recorder that contains
the Triffid’s noise. Masen has been recording the
noise over the years and has theorized that the
plants are communicating with each other.
Following that, they drive to Joe’s father's
house to make sure he is safe. However,
when they reach there, he has already been
killed and is being pulled away by the
branches of Triffid. With no way out,
the duo goes to a radio station and broadcasts the
news about the dangerous plant. They warn all the
listeners with sight to help the others get to
a safe place. Somewhere else, Torrance reaches
the current prime minister’s office and asks his
secretary about his whereabouts. After finding out
that the government has collapsed, he sets off
to look for weapons, aiming to be the people’s
next leader. In the morning, Masen sees flare
signals coming from the other part of the city.
He realizes that there are more people like them
and who have probably formed a community.
When the duo finally reaches the building where
all the survivors have gathered, they see that
the officials are not allowing blind people to
enter the premises. They are received by Michelle
Beadley, an employee of the home office and the
chief of the survivor’s organization. Currently,
the organization is working on providing food and
shelter to the affected people but is oblivious
to the problem of Triffids. When Masen tells them
about the real danger, Michelle asks him for his
expert advice. A clip shows us that the plants
have taken over the railway tracks and will soon
be in the streets of London. Michelle wants to
bring the little community of the sighted people
to a safe place and start anew, leaving the blind
to die. Masen and Joe do not support her idea
so they decide not to work with her. Out
in the streets, a sighted man named Coker
is gathering the blind people and is organizing
a search party for food and water to help them.
He has become the leader of the group. Torrance
sees that Coker is in power and asks to join
his team. They plan to raid the building with
sighted people to hold them hostage and force
them to help the blind. Meanwhile, Masen plans to
go to his father who lives in the countryside. His
father is also a bio engineer and a researcher on
Triffids. Masen believes that with his research,
they can find a way to contain the plants.
However, before they leave, they are attacked by
Coker and his group and are taken hostage. Coker
handcuffs each sighted person to a blind one and
gives them the responsibility to help them. His
heart is in the right place but he is oblivious
to the dangers of the Triffids. Following that,
they are taken to a warehouse to collect food and
supplies. But trouble arises when the warehouse
happens to be infested by Triffids. Joe is caught
in one of the branches but Masen saves her.
Coker realizes that Masen was right about the
Triffids. He asks Torrance to provide Masen with
everything he needs to get rid of the problem. But
since Torrance wants to be the leader, he plans
to betray Coker. When Joe is alone, he asks her
to broadcast another message on the radio asking
everyone to come to London for aid. In reality, he
wants to gather as many people as possible to rule
over them. Unknown to his true motives, she agrees
to do as he says. Meanwhile, his people take Coker
and Masen hostage, kicking them out of authority.
They are taken to a forest by Torrance’s
henchmen but are soon attacked by Triffids.
The plants kill all of Torrance’s men, and only
Masen and Coker come out of the forest alive.
The next morning, they reach a nearby church
where Masen is treated for his injuries.
The church is run by the head nun who claims
that they are immune to Triffid attacks.
Masen believes there is something she
is hiding. When Masen gets better,
he leaves to look for his father’s place while
Coker stays back in the Church. On his way, Masen
sees several bodies of nuns placed on crosses set
as a sacrifice to keep Triffids away. It turns
out that the head nun has been sacrificing people
to keep the church safe. He returns to the church
and reveals the truth to its people. They kick the
nun out of the place and thank Masen for his help.
Following that, he continues the journey to his
father’s house which is still a mile away.
In the meantime, Joe finds Masen’s tape
recorder that was found in an attack zone.
She realizes that Torrance has done something to
Coker and Masen to become the leader. In her next
radio broadcast, she tells the people that London
is not safer than the place they already live in,
hence they should stay put wherever they are. This
angers Torrance and he sends his men to kill her.
Joe manages to somehow escape the radio tower
and runs to the infested part of the city. The
henchmen try to catch her but are unsuccessful.
They believe that she can never survive among
the Triffids and quit looking for her. Joe is
attacked by an army of the plants but luckily,
she finds a working vehicle and drives away.
She is also driving to Masen’s father’s place,
having known where he lives. Meanwhile, Masen
reaches a small town where everyone has died
because of a Triffid attack except for two
little girls named Susan and Imogen. At first,
they fire at him, believing he is a robber but
stop when Masen explains he just needs a vehicle
to drive to his father’s place. The girls have
been living on their own since their parents died
and need an adult to take care of them. Masen
includes them in the mission and the three set
out to look for his father. After driving for
a few hours, they are stopped by a vehicle.
Coincidently, Masen’s father gets out of the
vehicle and asks them to join him. They drive
to his house in the middle of the woods that
is fenced with electrocuted wires. On going in,
Masen is shocked to see Joe. The two reunite,
relieved that they are alive. For a few minutes,
they forget the troubles of the outside world
and slow dance together. Back in London, Torrance
is tense because he has no means to save the
people he has gathered. He knows the only person
who can stop the plants is Masen. Meanwhile,
Masen’s father already has an elaborate plan
to get rid of the Triffids. He has been breeding
a female Triffid that is genetically modified to
sterilize the pollen from a male Triffid. If
these kinds of Triffids are spread all around,
they will make the entire population infertile,
and eventually, all of them will die out.
But he needs the pollen from a male Triffid for
the experiment to be completed. Masen sets out
to hunt a male Triffid and Susan comes with him.
They are in a warehouse trying to find one. Masen
uses his mother’s recordings of the Triffid
noise to attract the plant. Susan is attacked
by the plant that almost pulls her away before
Masen jumps on it and hits it repeatedly.
They bring its branch back to the house and start
the experiment. That night, Torrance gets his
hands on Masen’s report and finds out his father’s
address. They quickly leave for the countryside
to get them. Back in the house, a helicopter
flies above, distributing pamphlets everywhere.
Through the pamphlets, the group is informed about
a survivor’s colony in Isle of Wight where people
are providing food and water to everyone. After
defeating the Triffids, Masen and the group plan
to move there. His father is feeding the female
Triffid as usual, but this time, he listens to the
Triffid voice recording while doing so. The noise
makes the Triffid aggressive and it attacks the
old man. Masen comes to save his father and shoots
the Triffid dead. But it is too late because he
is already poisoned by the plant’s sting. Now,
since the plant is dead, they have no way to fight
against the Triffids. They cremate his father’s
dead body at night and decide to leave for Isle
of wight the next morning. While going through the
old stuff at the house, Masen finds a black mask
that he remembers wearing the day his mother died.
He doesn’t remember much about the day but he
knows that he was saved by a trivial group in an
African jungle who knew how to fight Triffids.
The next morning, Torrance and his men arrive at
the house and take everyone hostage. He asks Masen
for a way to fight the Triffids but even he has no
ideas left. An enraged Torrance orders him to come
up with a plan one way or the other, or he will
kill the girls. Masen knows there is no way to
stop the Triffids now. Instead, he prioritizes
getting everyone out of the house safely.
For that, he plans to use the Triffid recordings
to attract the plants. When Torrance and his
people are busy fighting them, the group
will have a chance to escape. That night,
the house is surrounded by Triffids as Masen had
planned. Torrance realizes that Masen was behind
all this and asks his right-hand man Troy to kill
the girls. Troy, however, has had enough of his
boss and doesn’t want to kill the little girls.
He sides with Masen and the team and protects
them. Soon, the Triffids take over them and kill
all of Torrance’s people. The others try to run
away but since the house is surrounded, they are
trapped. In the moment of panic, Masen remembers
the day his mother died. A man from the trivial
group had made Masen wear the mask and poured
Triffid venom around his eyes. The venom tricked
the plants into thinking he was one of them.
He does the same with everyone and carefully
steps outside the house. Low and behold,
the plants do not attack the group. Just then,
Torrance comes outside and starts firing at them.
He is caught in Triffid branches and killed while
the group escapes safely. In the last scene,
they are on their way to the isle of wight to
start a new life and fight the Triffids with
the knowledge they have gathered.
Subscribe for more videos like this,
turn on the notification, and leave a like to
help the channel out. Thank You for watching.